qu'on va avoir pour longtemps du monde
qui arrive au Canada comme ça Francis
habite à hemingford à côté du chemin
Roxane depuis plus de 40 ans elle a
connu et vu toute l'évolution de ce
passage devenue mondialement célèbre qui
accueille maintenant des milliers de
demandeurs d'asile au Québec tous les
mois au début c'était
un autobus
frontalier absolument les
investissements sont massifs
Ottawa déjà payé plus de 7 millions pour
installer des roulottes à côté de la
frontière des bâtiments vu le jour et de
nouvelles rénovations vont coûter plus
de 4 millions transporter les migrants
les nourrir et leur offrir des soins a
aussi fait gonfler la facture depuis de
20 millions ça a changé énormément
maintenant c'est vraiment en frontière
militarisée et moi je trouve ça
inquiétant mais le plus gros des
investissements concernent l'hébergement
de ces migrants et ce n'est pas tout le
gouvernement refuse de rendre public
plusieurs ententes en parlant
d'exception de sécurité nationale
votre contrats ont aussi été signés sans
appel d'offres des millions étaient
versés aux entreprises d'un homme
d'affaires Pierre gay que l'on voit ici
avec la députée fédérale libérale Brenda
Chana cette entrepreneur est un
important donateur du Parti libéral à
qui il a déjà versé plusieurs milliers
de dollars de dons il loue gouvernement
des terrains à côté de la frontière
pierre gay a refusé de nous parler et
Ottawa vient de renouveler plusieurs de
ses ententes jusqu'en 2027 ces décisions
ont fait réagir tant à Québec à Ottawa
tous les contrats tous les montants et
tous les fournisseurs on va travailler
avec les États-Unis pour assurer que
notre système d'asile restait juste
équitable et transparent ça ressemble à
si méprendre au début du scandale des
commentaires c'est astronomique là ils
ont mis ça pour des installations
illégales maintenant il faut que ça
arrête et pendant ce temps le flou de
demandeur d'asile qui se presse au Maroc
Sam ne cesse de croître depuis le début
de l'année plus de 23000 personnes sont
entrées au Canada par cet endroit c'est
un record
ici romain Suez Radio-Canada Montréal